Welcome to Bible Answers Live, where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions.
Let's face it, it's not always easy to
understand everything you read in the
Bible. With 66 books and more than
700,000 words, the Bible can generate a
lot of questions. If you'd like answers
to your Bible questions, you've come to
the right place. Now, here's your host,
Pastor Doug Batchelor, president and
speaker of Amazing Facts.
You'd like to hear an amazing fact?
You might be surprised to learn the
world's biggest grapevine is not in
France or Spain or Italy or one of the
Mediterranean countries where grapes
typically thrive. It's in England.
That's right. The Hampton Court
grapevine was planted back in 1768 by
Lancelot Brown.
120 years later in 1887, it was measured
and found to be 4 ft around the base.
Today, it's 13 ft around the base and
the longest branch is 120 ft.
In fact, the Hampton Court Palace
grapevine is the largest and oldest
grapevine in the world.
During its 250-year life, it has
outlived five or six glass greenhouses
that have been built and dismantled
around it.
Throughout the year, the grapevine is
carefully pruned, fertilized, and
thinned by specialists that are trained
in viticulture.
Because of all of this tender care, back
in 2001, this single grapevine produced
over 845 lb of delicious black dessert
grapes.
Queen Victoria used to have the grapes
sent to the royal household at Windsor,
but in 1909, King Edward VII decided the
royal household could not use so many
grapes, so they would be sold to
visitors. Incredible. 845 lb from one
grapevine. You know, the Bible tells us
that Jesus compares himself with a
grapevine. Stay with us, friends. We're
going to talk about it as Amazing Facts
brings you this edition of Bible Answers
Live.
You're listening to Bible Answers Live,
honest answers to your Bible questions.
Our phone lines are now open. If you
have a Bible-related question, call us
at 1-800-God
Says. That's 1-800-463-7297.
Now, let's join our host, Pastor Doug
Batchelor, and our co-host, Pastor Jean
Ross.
Welcome, listening friends, to Bible
Answers Live, and we are live, and we
have lines open. If you have a Bible
question, we'd encourage you to give us
a call. It is a free phone call, and the
number is
brings you here to the studio. One more
time, 800-God Says, 800-463-7297.
Give them a call right now. Excellent
odds your question will be on tonight's
program. My name is Doug Batchelor.
My name is Jean Ross. Good evening,
listening friends, and Pastor Doug,
let's start the program with prayer.
Dear Father, once again, we thank you
for the opportunity to study your word
together, and Lord, we ask for your
spirit to guide our hearts and be with
those listening wherever they might be.
Lead us into a clear understanding of
your word. For you have said, "They
shall know the truth, and the truth will
set you free." Thank you, Lord, for your
promise to be with us. In Jesus' name.
Amen. Amen. Pastor Doug, you opened the
program by talking about this incredible
vine. I mean, talk about a big vine. Not
only is it big, but it's very
productive. Produced tremendous amounts
of grape, and I guess these grapes are
are pretty good. Well, if they were
providing dessert for the palace, they
must have been pretty good. But, it's
amazing that it would, you know, it's
older than some redwood trees, a
grapevine.
But, you know, when you think about a
grapevine, it is kind of interesting
that you got the vine coming out of the
ground, and then, you know, 100 ft away,
it's carrying all the nourishment and
producing this luscious fruit so far
away from the source of the earth and
the nutrients and the minerals. And
Jesus uses that illustration to make one
of his most beautiful lessons for us in
John 15.
He says, "I am the true vine, and my
father is the vine dresser.
Every branch in me, all the branches
that are, you know, connected to the
vine, that does not bear fruit, he takes
it away, prunes it. And every branch
that bears fruit, he prunes it that it
may more fruit. You're already clean
because of the word that I have spoken
to you. Abide in me, and I in you. As
the branch cannot bear fruit by itself
unless it abides in the vine, neither
can you unless you abide in me. I am the
vine, you are the branches. He that
abides in me, and I in him, bears much
fruit. For without me, you can do
nothing.
You know, the Bible tells us there in
Galatians chapter 5 that
the evidence that a Christian has been
transformed by the Holy Spirit is they
will have the fruits of the spirit. And
it's, you know, love. It's Galatians
5:22, love, joy, peace, long-suffering,
goodness, faith, meekness, mercy.
All of this is going to be seen in the
believer's life if they are abiding in
Christ. The the power of God and the
love of Christ transforms us and makes
us new creatures. And I know there's a
lot of people that are listening that
maybe have grown up in a church, you've
grown up in a Christian home, you go to
church, you do the outward Christian
things,
but you know in your heart you don't
have that love, that joy, that peace,
and you long to have the fruits of the
spirit. We have a special offer that's
going to tell you how to have a
productive, fruitful life by being
connected to the vine, and it's free.
All you'll have to do is give us a call
on our resource phone number, and you
can ask for the study guide called A
Love That Transforms. The number is
800-835-6747,
and ask for the study guide called A
Love That Transforms. One more time,
yes, it's the resource phone number.
It's 800-835-6747.
And if you have a Bible question, our
phone line here to the studio is
800-463-
7297.
That's 800-463-72-
97. Mhm. Well, I think we're ready to go
to our first caller this evening. We
have Sebastian listening from Palm
Beach, Florida. Sebastian, welcome to
the program.
Hey, good evening, Pastor Ross. Good
evening, Pastor Doug Batchelor. Thank
you for taking my call.
Sure, we're glad to talk with you.
Okay. Well,
I know that in the books of Zechariah
and then in the books of Psalm that
there are prophecies that
reference Christ's betrayal. And so, my
question is, was Judas predestined to
betray Christ?
No, I don't think so, and this is a
great question,
and it's had, boy, lots of debate from
theologians through the ages.
Some would argue yes, Jesus uh Judas was
predestined to betray Jesus.
Um I see a difference biblically between
God being all-knowing and being able to
predict what happens
and a person still having a choice.
While God knew what Judas would do, God
knows everything. He knows everything in
the future, he knows everything in the
past, he's all-knowing. He knows
who listening is going to be saved and
who's not.
That doesn't mean he's making it happen.
We still have choices, and we need to
live
as if we have those choices.
Jesus gave Judas every opportunity to
change his mind. You know, he went to
wash his feet, and I think he appealed
to him, but um
he hardened his heart.
And so, it's not like God was creating
creatures, and he said, "You know, we've
got to make one be the fall guy that
will betray Jesus.
Uh sorry, Judas, but you're going to
have to be the traitor. I'm going to
make you to be a traitor. And then after
you betray Jesus, doing just what I
created you to do, then I'm going to
throw you in hell."
It Can you see there'd be a problem with
that? It almost makes God an accessory
to the crime.
Yes, I see.
So, I I think God knows what was going
to happen, and he predicted it in the
prophecies. You're right about that.
But, I don't think that Judas was born
with the mission
that he should betray Christ.
Everyone is born with a free will and an
opportunity.
Yes, okay, cuz the act is um that was
just something that, you know, has
really been like been peaking my
interest in the whole the Judas
situation, and, you know, whether or not
he was
predestined, but I've always known that
he had the freedom of choice because,
you know, God gives everybody the
freedom of choice, but I just wanted to
get some clarification on his particular
situation. So, so thank you, Pastor
Doug.
Thanks, Sebastian. Appreciate your call.
You know, we have a book talking about
this idea that with us free will coming
to our salvation and freedom to choose.
The book is called Can a Saved Man
Choose to Be Lost? And I will be happy
to send it to anybody who calls and
asks, dealing with the subject of
predestination.
All you'll need to do is call us on our
resource phone number. The number is
800-835-6747.
You can ask for the book called Can a
Saved Man Choose to Be Lost? We'll be
happy to send that to anybody who calls
and asks. You can also read it for free
online at the AmazingFacts.org.
Our next call is Christopher, and he's
listening from uh New York. Christopher,
welcome to the program.
Good afternoon, good evening. Evening,
and your question tonight?
Yes, I like to know
your biblical definition of everlasting
fire in Matthew 25:41.
All right, I'm going to go there real
quick. And here Jesus is sharing a
parable where he's talking about the
sheep and the goats.
And he said
he'll then say to those on his left
hand, "Depart from me, you cursed, into
everlasting fire prepared for the devil
and his angels."
And so you want to know what do you
think what does everlasting there mean?
Yeah, what what's the biblical
definition of everlasting?
Well, the word everlasting there means I
think it's aionios, which means eons,
but it I believe it means everlasting.
But what is everlasting there is um
it's the destruction of the fire lasts
forever.
There's no repentance. There's no second
chance. What the fire does is it's going
to be everlasting. Now, one reason we
know this, and I forget the verse off
hand where it talks about Sodom and
Gomorrah are destroyed with eternal
fire.
The Lord tells us that the way that he's
going to deal with the wicked is the
same way that he dealt with Sodom and
Gomorrah. And it tells us Sodom and
Gomorrah were destroyed with eternal
fire. That's Jude 7. Jude verse 7.
There's only one chapter in Jude. Jude
verse 7. You want to read that for us?
Yes, as Sodom and Gomorrah, the cities
and the cities around them in similar
manner to these, having given themselves
over to sexual immorality and gone after
strange flesh, are set forth as an
example and then here's the point,
suffering the vengeance of eternal fire.
Other translations say everlasting fire.
Right. And so it's just telling us that
those cities were burned up. The Bible
says they were never rebuilt.
And the result of that fire was
everlasting.
So, does that make sense, Christopher?
So, the the cursed that's going to be
cast into this fire
is the fire is going to be put out?
Well, the Bible says that the wicked, if
you look in Malachi chapter 4,
it says the day is coming that will burn
as an oven and all the proud and all
that do wickedly will be burnt up. It
will leave them neither root nor branch.
Uh and it Bible tells us they will be
consumed. So, there is a lake of fire.
There is punishment and everyone is
rewarded according to his works.
But ultimately, the Lord is going to
make all things new. Revelation says
there's no more pain or sorrow or death.
Uh the former things have passed away.
All things are made new.
So, yes, we believe what the Christians
believed many years ago
that um
Bible tells us that ultimately the fires
of hell consume the wicked.
That they perish.
And that they yeah, they God does not
have an eternal torture chamber where a
zillion years down the line
he has people writhing in sulfur and
brimstone and they've only just begun.
A billion years go by and they're still
just begun.
But that's now Malachi 4:1, that's
that's in the Old Covenant. And Jesus
came in to bring in the New Covenant. He
said that the Old Covenant passes away.
All right. Well, let's let's look at
some new
the fire
Let's look at some New Testament. is
everlasting. He said the punishment is
everlasting and the life eternal is
everlasting
in 46 and they're both the same the same
Greek word. Now, do you believe that the
bodies are burned or the souls continue
to burn or both body and soul continue
to burn or what do you believe?
I believe that both both body and soul
is going to be cast into the lake of
fire.
And the the the the sinner is going to
pay for his uh for his sins eternally
cuz uh
cuz uh if if if there's no eternal
eternal punishment
there's no there's no purpose in you
know for Jesus dying on the cross. You
could just live in fornication in your
whole life you're just going to die.
Now, is the only reason you want to live
in fornication because you're afraid of
eternal punishment?
No, you you you you live in fornication
cuz there's no consequences to the sin.
Cuz you're just going to die.
if a person if a person goes to the lake
of fire and they burn according to what
they deserve, just suppose for a moment
they burn for a month, that'd be pretty
bad. I mean, that would I think that'd
be a major deterrent. Uh does a person
need to burn for for ever and ever
in order for there it to be a deterrent?
I don't think that hell should be the
reason anyone serves the Lord. I think
love ought to be the reason we serve the
Lord.
Yeah, that's for the Christian, but the
sinner the sinner the impenitent sinners
have to be punished for their sins cuz
God is God
of eternity.
We agree with that.
Eternity is to have but they they're
going to live forever in in either
heaven or hell. You and I agree
is eternal. You and I agree that the
sinner is going to be punished. There's
no disagreement on that. The Bible is
very clear there is a lake of fire. It
says the wicked are cast into the lake
of fire. It calls it the second death.
Where I think we disagree is how long
they stay in that lake of fire. Uh I
believe when God says there is no more
pain, all things are made new, that sin
is not immortalized forever and ever.
Uh that the sinner does not get eternal
life. Eternal life is promised to those
who accept Jesus. Without the sun there
is no life. The God told Adam and Eve,
"When you disobey, you will die."
And death means the absence of life. And
you're saying that they're alive
in a medieval torture chamber through
ceaseless ages. I mean, just think about
that. You got some, you know,
14-year-old. He's past the age of
accountability.
And he's going to burn just as long as
Adolf Hitler and Joseph Stalin.
So,
uh there's really no justice in there.
Hey, I you know, Christopher, we have to
take some other calls. I appreciate your
question and we will send you a free
study guide on this that has all these
scriptures that you're talking about.
It's called "Is the Devil in Charge of
Hell?" Yes, the number to call is
800-835-6747.
You can ask for the study guide called
"Is the Devil in Charge of Hell?" We'll
be happy to send this to you,
Christopher, or anybody who calls and
asks. That number again is 800-835-6747.
We also have a website that's dedicated
to the subject of what happens to the
wicked and it's called helltruth.com.
Great amount of resources, some video
you can actually watch, some sermons,
uh some some books, study materials.
Take a look at it. helltruth.com. I
think you'll find it very helpful. Thank
you for your call, Christopher.
Our next call is Gabriel listening from
Riverdale, Iowa. Gabriel, welcome to the
program.
Hi.
Hi. And your question tonight?
Uh what
where did God
God come from?
I don't know. You've asked the hardest
question so far.
Um and now there's some things Let me
just see if I can answer this way,
Gabriel. There are some things that are
a great mystery.
And even the brightest minds in the
universe
don't know where everything came from.
Now, I believe in God
and I believe that God has always
existed. I know it's hard for us to
comprehend that.
But it's, you know, something like a
circle that doesn't have an end or a
beginning. God
is from everlasting to everlasting, the
Bible says.
It's kind of like you could go around
the world from east to west and you'll
never get to the end. You just keep
going.
Um
so, he's always existed. Now, some
people that don't believe in God, they
believe in evolution. They think
that, you know, the universe was formed
when there was a
an explosion
and the Big Bang and our solar system
came from a Big Bang. And then you say,
"Well, where did where did what caused
the Big Bang?" Well, there were these
gas particles in this nebula and they
collided. I said, "Well, where did the
gas particles come from?"
And even scientists that don't believe
in God will say, "Well, we don't know.
Something always existed."
Cuz one thing we know, Gabriel, is that
from nothing you get nothing.
So, something has to exist to get
something.
So, God has always existed.
Now, I know it's kind of those are some
deep things. Does that make sense?
You there?
That helps a little bit maybe, huh?
Uh-huh. But don't you think God has to
come from somewhere? Well, where do you
think he comes?
Uh
I'm not sure. Yeah, well, me you and I
are together on that. I think that God's
So, I mean, in order for somebody to
create God
then they would have had to be God.
And so,
uh you know,
do you play with LEGO?
Uh-huh.
Do you ever make anything out of LEGO?
Uh-huh. What's the most interesting
thing you made? Tell me real quick.
A
LEGO bridge. All right. Now, when you
look at a LEGO bridge, did it happen by
itself or do you can you tell that
someone had to use intelligence to make
that bridge?
Uh Someone had to use their brain to
make that bridge, right? That was you,
okay?
Whenever you see something that's got
order and design
it means there's an intelligence that
made it.
And you are a lot more complicated than
a LEGO bridge.
Which means that there's an intelligence
that made you. And that that genius,
that intelligence that made you is God.
And he made all things.
And so he's always existed. And we don't
know. It's a mystery where he came from.
But I sure appreciate your call,
Gabriel. And um you know, you would
enjoy that number one study guide that
we send out sometimes, "Is There
Anything Left You Can Trust?" The number
to call is 800-835-6747.
That is the resource phone number and
you can ask for study guide number one.
Actually, you know what, Gabriel, I
think you'll also enjoy a series of
lessons that Pastor Doug did for kids
called "Amazing Adventure." Yeah. Now, I
don't think we can give that away for
free, but maybe your mom and your dad
can get it at the Amazing Facts website.
It's called "Amazing Adventure." Whole
set of 10 lessons that are very
interactive. I think you'll enjoy that.
That's right. Friends, if you have a
Bible question, the phone line here to
the studio is 800-463-7297.
Again, that number is 800-463-7297
with going to go to our next caller now
and we've got um let's see, we've got
Carol listening in or from uh Ohio. Uh
Carol, welcome to the program.
Hello.
Hi, thanks for your call.
Hi.
Oh, thank you. Um
I have a question about Jeremiah 45:5.
Okay.
Um especially the last part. The whole
thing says, "And seekest thou great
things for thyself? Seek them not. For
behold, I will bring evil upon all
flesh, saith the Lord. But thy life"
this is the part that gets me. "Thy life
will I give unto thee for a prey in all
places whither thou goest." What does
that mean?
Well,
um
it for one thing when it says, "Your
life will give you as a prize" and I'm
reading the
as a prey for all the places.
the New King James Version, you're
reading the King James Version. We're
looking at the same verse.
Yeah. Okay.
And it basically means that um
Israel was about to be Jerusalem was
about to be destroyed by Babylon.
Many people would perish in that war.
Yeah.
God is telling Jeremiah,
you know, don't have big plans for
what's going to happen in Jerusalem
because but I'm going to save your life.
Okay.
And uh I'm going to give your life as a
prize. And Jeremiah did survive the
destruction of Jerusalem. Matter of
fact, they
they the chief guard said, you know, he
gave him a cash reward and said, "Do you
want to go to Babylon with us? Do you
want to stay here?" And he chose to
stay.
And so he was uh he was spared through
it all.
Wow.
But the city and the the nation was
destroyed just decimated. Temple was
burnt. Uh the palaces were burnt.
Uh it was basically turned to rubble
because of their rebellion.
Mhm.
Okay.
Well, that that makes it a little easier
to understand.
Yeah, and what he did for Jeremiah, he
also did for the nation in that even
though Israel was carried off captive,
Judah was carried to Babylon.
He preserved them there as a nation and
brought them back again. Wherever they
went, he kept them alive as a nation.
And they you know, that happened not
only were they destroyed by
the Babylonians, they were you know,
conquered by the Egyptians, they came
back again, they came back from Babylon,
then they were conquered by the Romans
for 1900 years and in 1948, they came
back again. So God has preserved Israel
as a nation in a miraculous way unlike
any other nation in the world.
True.
True. I I just a short little question
to ask you. Um when the
um
Israelites left Egypt, did they have
animals and how did they feed them?
Yeah, they did. They had quite a bit of
livestock. Matter of fact, um
when Moses told Pharaoh, "We're we we're
going in the wilderness." Pharaoh said,
"You can go but leave your animals
here." And Moses said, "No, we need our
animals cuz some of them we're going to
use as sacrifices."
Yeah.
Um
the the Sinai Peninsula and even Saudi
Arabia back you're talking
almost 4,000 years ago
uh was a lot more um temperate and they
had grass and they had cattle and flocks
and you can read the Book of Job and the
area around Edom
um Job had vast flocks and herds and
they had to be a lot more pasture and
grass. Even in North Sahara, there's
petroglyphs
in the desert that show crocodiles and
giraffes and all these savanna animals
and
so the desert the climate's changed a
lot in 4,000 years. It used to be a lot
more pasture land back then.
Okay, so the wilderness was just away
from city, not not necessarily desert.
Yeah, it wasn't the dry sandy desert
that it is now. It was a little more of
grasslands.
Okay.
All right.
able to feed their flocks. The problem
they had, they never once said the whole
wilderness wandering, they never once
said there's no food for our flocks.
They did say there's no water.
Mhm.
there must have always been grass.
Mhm. Okay.
Okay. All right. Hey, thank you for your
question.
I appreciate it.
Our next caller is um Michael listening
from Miami, Florida. Michael, welcome to
the program.
Hello, Pastor Doug, Pastor Ross.
Hello.
Hello, good evening.
Um so yeah, my question is uh the
confusion that I have when I was reading
out of Proverbs. I was reading Proverbs
chapter 26, verse 4 and verse 5 is where
I kind of
got a little confused. Oh, yeah.
Because it seemed they seem to
contradict each other. You know, it
says, "Answer not a fool according to
his folly, lest thou also be like unto
him." And then verse 5 says, "No, no,
it's like the direct opposite. It says,
"Answer a fool according to his own
folly,
lest he be wise in his own conceit."
And I I know Solomon sometimes speaks I
guess a bit enigmatically in Proverbs,
but I was just wondering if you could
shed a little light on that.
Well, we've got a few similar
expressions
uh in English
that go along with what Solomon is
saying here that uh
uh you lose either way
is basically what he's saying.
Um
Oh, okay. A- and Solomon is using a
little bit of irony here. He said,
"Don't answer a fool according to his
folly." If he's talking foolishly and
you answer him according to his foolish
question, you start sounding like him.
But he's saying if you don't answer him,
he's going to think he's right. So no
matter what, when you talk to a fool,
you're going to lose.
Oh.
It's kind of what Solomon is saying.
He's this is a statement he's making
tongue-in-cheek.
If you if you answer a fool, you start
sounding foolish. If you don't answer a
fool, he's going to think he's made a
point and he's right and you're
speechless. So you got to answer him,
but then you start sounding foolish. He
says, "You're going to lose when you
talk to a fool."
Okay.
All right.
Yeah, and that's you know, in the verse
proceeding, he says quite a few things
about the fool.
If you know, he he's talks about fools
in verse 3, he talks about fools in
verse 7. He's just uh
Solomon who was the wisest man who ever
lived was probably irritated when people
ask silly questions.
Almost as if Solomon is thinking out
loud and he says, "Well, I don't answer
the fool." And then he thinks, "Well,
wait a minute. If I don't answer the
fool, then he's going to think he's
wise. So no, then answer." So it just
you know, you can't win either way. When
you're communicating with a fool, it's
there's not a lot of a whole lot of
options that's available.
I think most people out there can relate
to that at some point in their life.
Yeah.
I'm wondering would that would that then
mean like if I guess if I were to come
across I don't want to call anyone a
fool, but if I were to come across a
fool, so to speak,
um should I answer them in their
according to their own folly? I don't
know. I think you're better not. You
know what? There's one more verse.
Solomon said uh
"He that restrains his lips is wise. And
even when a fool holds his peace, he's
esteemed wise." And so I sometimes I've
been in board meetings I knew were way
over my head. I don't say anything so
people will think I'm smart. But uh
And so yeah, there there's when you're
in doubt, don't say anything. You're
usually safer.
Hey, we we really appreciate your your
question, Michael, for giving us a call.
Now friends, in just a moment, we're
going to be taking a break. We do have
some lines open and we're going to be
coming back second half of the program.
We want to hit the ground running. And
so I see some of you standing by, David,
Sally, Jason. We're going to get your
calls in just a minute. And there are
other lines open. If you have a Bible
question, give us a call. Here's the
number again. 800, you ready? 463-7297.
800-463-7297.
Also, even as we're listening, if you're
near a smartphone or computer or an iPad
or some device, if you've not been to
the Amazing Facts website, we hope that
you'll go there. It is one of the
busiest Christian websites on the
internet. I'm just I'm not just saying
that. You type in the word Amazing Facts
on Google on Yahoo, it takes you to our
site because there are so many Bible
resources there that people are using.
We hope you'll find that a blessing.
Going to take a break, get a breath,
drink a water, be right back. Call in
with your questions.
Stay tuned. Bible Answers Live will
return in a moment.
Amazing Facts began in 1965
with a God-inspired concept. Hello, this
is Joe Crews on the Amazing Facts
broadcast, facts which affect you. Each
radio broadcast would begin with an
amazing fact from science, nature, or
history followed by a Bible message that
touched the hearts of listeners from
every walk of life. The program was an
instant success and the ministry soon
began expanding to include Bible
lessons. In 1986, Amazing Facts added
the medium of television to its growing
outreach efforts, offering soul-winning
evangelistic messages for viewers around
the world. In 1994, Pastor Doug
Batchelor assumed leadership of the
ministry, adding the Bible Answers Live
call-in radio program and new ministry
TV programs began airing on multiple
networks around the world. For 50 years,
the driving vision of Amazing Facts has
been the bold proclamation of the
everlasting gospel. And with a team of
evangelists circling the globe and
thousands of men and women being trained
through the Amazing Facts Center of
Evangelism program, AFCO, the ministry
is helping God's church see a rich
harvest of souls.
Amazing Facts, God's message, our
mission.
Every Bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life.
So, what are you waiting for? Get the
answers you need for a fuller, richer,
more confident life.
You're listening to Bible Answers Live.
We still have a few phone lines open. If
you have a Bible-related question, call
us at 1-800-God Says. That's
1-800-463-7297.
Now, let's join Pastors Doug Batchelor
and Jean Ross for more Bible Answers
Live.
We're back and we are all ready to go.
We do still have a line or two open.
Again, 800-463-7297.
And we're thankful if you joined along
the way. This is Bible Answers Live
where we are doing a live,
international, interactive Bible study.
And my name is Doug Batchelor. My name
is Jean Ross and we got Sally listening
from uh
KY. Where do you Where do you
Kentucky, that's where it is. Sally,
welcome to the program.
Hi there. Hi, how are you doing?
Okay.
And your question?
Okay, you know, you just answered a
gentleman's question about
predestination and Judas. Yeah. And and
I was good with that answer except that
in the Bible it tells that the devil did
enter Judas
to have him to go do what he did. So,
was that still Judas' free will?
Well, at one point, a person can grieve
away the Holy Spirit and be possessed.
And before Satan entered Judas, that
means he wasn't controlling Judas.
Right? So, when Judas finally, at the
Last Supper,
when Jesus said, "One of you is going to
betray me." Judas had a chance to repent
and confess. Christ was washing his
feet.
But when Judas said, "Lord, is it I?"
like he didn't know. He knew it was.
Yeah. And then finally, Jesus said, "Go
do what you do quickly."
And Judas knew what he was talking
about. That point, Satan entered Judas.
He'd probably reached the point of no
return then and committed the
unpardonable sin.
And that it doesn't mean that uh was
predestined all of a sudden. It just
means that um his death his doom was
fixed at that point. Satan was
controlling him then.
Satan was also controlling him when
Judas hung himself cuz the devil often
discourages a person and leads them to
despair and suicide.
Okay.
I just never heard that part explained.
I I like that.
Well, good. I'm I'm glad that makes
sense and we appreciate your calling in,
Sally. Thank you very much.
The phone line here to the studio, if
you have a Bible question, is
800-463-7297.
We do have some lines open. Good time to
call. 800- 463-72-
97. And we have Jason who is listening
from Wisconsin. Jason, welcome to the
program.
Hey.
I'm doing all right tonight.
Good. And uh what's your question?
See,
uh I was talking with my mother-in-law
about disciplining my children.
And she said that there's
if we're going to follow the Bible,
there should be verses in there about,
you know, what we should and shouldn't
do, but I can't find any.
Well, there's several verses I think
that talk about um
how to train your children. Uh you know,
of course, the Bible says, "Fathers, do
not provoke your children to wrath." In
other words, you want to be fair and
just with them. And so, to be loving.
Uh there are
uh verses that talk about appropriate
discipline.
And it says, you know, um "He that loves
his son chastens him."
And that chastisement might mean time
out in the corner. And when they're
younger, sometimes it may mean corporal
punishment. Um the Bible talks about
part of family discipline is to train
them by reading the word of God and
telling them the principles of God's
law, what's right and wrong, from a very
early age. And it says, "When they rise
up, when you come through the house,
when you go to bed at night."
And just, you know, surrounding them
with the principles. Pastor Ross did a
program on family and child rearing a
couple of years ago. Yeah, we did. And
you know, the verse that comes to mind
is Proverbs chapter 22 verse 6, which
says, "Train up a child in the way that
he should go,
and when he's old, he'll not depart from
it." So, from a very early age, we ought
to be training our children in love,
guiding them. And of course, one of the
biggest ways to teach our children is by
example. So, parents in living out their
faith, they're an example to their kids.
And then also encouraging them and
disciplining as needed, but um leaving
them alone, training them.
Someone said once that while children
may not listen to their parents, they
almost always imitate them. Mhm. That's
true. So, And someone else said uh
Christianity is more caught than taught.
Uh kids catch it cuz they see their
parents living it out or they don't. And
then that's a different problem.
Well, I perfect answers.
Well, appreciate your call. You know, um
if uh that series you probably see it on
YouTube about the family series that you
did. You know, I don't know if it is,
but um it's called Raising Your Kids for
Heaven. If you just go to the uh Amazing
Facts website and type that in,
amazingfacts.org
or .com, type in that Raising Kids for
Heaven, I think it it'll direct you
there.
Appreciate your call, Jason. I just
wrote that down. All right, thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller is David listening from um
Minnesota. David, welcome to the
program. That's Michigan, I think.
Michigan.
You have me stopped on all of these
abbreviations here.
Pastor Ross is from South Africa and so
he struggles with some of our the
acronyms here.
pretty close together, Michigan and
Minnesota. They're up there somewhere,
so.
It's okay, no problem.
Hi Pastors. Uh thank you for taking my
call. You know, I rejoice in my
salvation uh that Jesus has given me uh
so much. I'm finding that I'm having
some difficulty understanding what the
scriptures talked about in 2
Thessalonians chapter 2
um about this man of sin um here in
chapter 2. I know he's kind of spoken of
a little bit by the Apostle Paul. And
the Apostle says that the mystery of
iniquity is already working. And so, um
you know, I'm wondering and needing more
knowledge about who who is this man of
sin? How can he be recognized,
especially after the Apostle had
mentioned that um that day uh that he
speaks of here isn't going to come until
he's revealed or till he's recognized.
And so, how can we recognize him more
for uh who he is and and like all that
he actually is?
Yeah, great question there in
Thessalonians. And let me just read the
verse for our friends that are driving.
And I'll start with verse 3. This is uh
2 Thessalonians chapter 2 verse 3. "Let
no one deceive you by any means, for
that day," speaking of the day of the
Lord, "will not come unless a falling
away comes first, and the man of sin is
revealed, the son of perdition, who
opposes and exalts himself above all
that is called God or worshipped, so
that he sits as God in the temple of
God, showing himself that he is God."
So, here it's talking about this this
office, this person that is going to be
putting themselves uh in the place of
God, showing themselves there that they
are God. Now, a common mistake I think
is made in in many dear people in the
Christian world, when it says, "Sitting
in the temple of God, showing himself he
is God." Well, when
Paul wrote this, the Jewish temple was
about to be destroyed, and it's never
been rebuilt since 70 AD. And so, some
look at this verse and say, "In order
for this Antichrist power," now, you
know, there John says there are many
Antichrists, but this is certainly an
Antichrist power,
"sitting in the temple of God," that
means they must rebuild the Jewish
temple. Not necessarily. Uh you know,
the Bible says that the church is the
temple of God. Paul says, "What, don't
you know that you are the temple of
God?" And Jesus said,
Okay. "Destroy this temple made with
hands and I will make one without
hands." So, that's the body of Christ.
So, this Antichrist power puts himself
over the church or the temple of God,
asking for worship, saying that he is
God, or taking at least divine
privileges,
uh claiming divine privileges. You know,
to to fully answer what that power is
and who this individual is,
I'd like to send you our study guide for
free. It's called Who Is the Antichrist?
Because it's just going to take too long
to go through it all.
I we'd have to go to Daniel 7 and
Revelation 13 and several verses. But
can we send you a copy of that, David?
You surely can.
All right, then. Pastor Ross will give
you the number. It's a free phone call
and no one will harass you. We'll just
send you the lesson. The number to call
is 800-835-6747.
You can ask the study guide called Who
Is the Antichrist? And we'll be happy to
send that to anybody who calls and asks.
Again, the number is 800-
835-6747.
Ask the study guide Who Is the
Antichrist? Our phone line here to the
studio with a Bible question is
800-463-7297.
And we have Chris that is listening from
Chico, California. Chris, welcome to the
program.
Hello, Pastor Ross and Pastor Batchelor.
Hi.
Oh, hi. Uh the question I had, I was
talking to a friend of mine uh from a
certain denomination,
and he seems to think that God or Jesus,
when he died,
didn't go to the right hand of the
Father afterwards.
Well, when Christ
Well, first of all,
uh God is omnipresent, right?
Right.
So,
the idea that um
you know, Christ could be separated from
God. Uh the only time Jesus was
separated from God was when he was on
the cross and when he's suffering for
our sins.
Right. The Father basically forsook him
for us. Cuz he experienced what the
sinner experiences.
But, God also does have a dwelling
place. When we pray, we say, "Our
Father, which art in heaven." Because
there's a place where he dwells. Even
though he is a spiritual being, he does
seem to have a body of some form.
Uh and he is in this heavenly temple.
Uh when Christ rose from the dead, he
told Mary, "Do not cling to me." This is
John 21.
"For I've not yet ascended to my father,
but go to the brethren and say I go to
my God and your God."
Uh and to my father and your father. So,
Christ ascended to the father. He was
coronated. He was seated, throned,
victorious
uh at the right hand of the father as
soon as he ascended.
Right.
But, then and that basically activated
his
That activated his work as our high
priest.
And where he continues to serve. And
then you read in Hebrews, Jesus is
before the father and he serves as our
high priest.
And for the first, you know, couple
thousand years of church history or
nearly 1,800 years, Jesus was us going
through the
what, you know, the comparable service
of what a priest would have done on a
daily basis.
Uh interceding in behalf of the lost.
The Bible says he ever lives to make
intercession for us.
Um
but then as we entered the last age of
the church, the late age of Laodicea,
Christ has entered into the holy of
holies now.
Um kind of a heavenly day of atonement
just before he comes. So, I don't know
if this is what you're talking about and
or
does that make sense?
Yeah, I was just reading Colossians and
um so that then you have been raised
with Christ. Seek the things that are
above where Christ is seated at the
right hand of God, which would be the
holy of holies cuz there's no holier
place than the right hand of God.
Yeah, I don't know that you know, we got
to be careful not to
fix Jesus into one geographic position.
Say, you know, for the last 2,000 years,
kind of like when you're on an airplane
and going through turbulence, the pilot
says, "Don't anyone get out of their
seat."
Jesus has not been buckled in for 2,000
years. The The idea that he can't get up
and move around or do anything. He is
certainly honored and enthroned by the
father, but he's also ministering as our
high high priest in heaven.
And I think Jesus
you know, talks to you and the other
beings in the universe and his angels.
He's not, like I said, just strapped in.
So,
Yeah, just one additional thought on
that. It doesn't mean that the father
God the father is also limited
exclusively to the most holy place for
the last 2,000 years. It's quite
possible that the father could have also
been in that first compartment of the
heavenly sanctuary with the son. So, you
know, Daniel kind of gives the idea that
at some point God the father, called the
ancient of days, moves into the most
holy place.
And then one like unto the son of man,
which would be Christ, enters in and
this heavenly judgment begins in heaven.
So,
yeah, this is probably several verses
that kind of give us that idea. What
you're reading there in Colossians, of
course, we all agree with that. And uh
Jesus uh is uh with the father. Mhm.
Hey, thank you very much for you We do
have that study guide that talks about
the sanctuary. Yeah, called God drew the
plans. And I think you get your free
copy
if you'd like, Chris. The number to call
for that is 800-835-6747.
You can ask for the study guide called
God drew the plans. Again, 800-835-
6747. And the study guide's name is God
drew the plans. Our next caller is uh
let's see. Eva listening from Vancouver,
Washington. Eva, welcome to the program.
Hi. Hi, Eva. How are you?
I'm just fine. Thank you.
And your question tonight?
Okay. Um the wars
and how God would have them destroy like
groups of people and and even um the
livestock and the women and
and all that in the Old Testament. Is
that symbolic for today
where it's a where it's spiritual
warfare?
Um
fighting against the evil?
Well, you're you're very perceptive. Um
when the children of Israel came into
the promised land, the Lord was
concerned that if they spared
some of these people that were involved
in very uh disgusting pagan practices.
Mhm. Uh there were a lot of sexual
rituals and disease and it was uh some
of those nations they uh child
sacrifice. And the Lord said, "Don't
spare them because you'll intermarry
with them and then you will follow their
ways and you'll forsake me."
And that's it, you know, they didn't
com- obey the Lord. They did spare some
of them. They did intermarry and they
did uh wander from God. Uh all the
things that God said would happen would
happen.
In our lives, when we come to Jesus, he
wants us to get rid of all the other
idols.
All the things that are taking us away
from the Lord need to be forsaken.
And so, you're right in that sense that
you know, we shouldn't make alliances in
our lives uh with the world.
Right.
Okay. Those things need to be
you know, we need to plow up the ground.
If you leave any weeds, it's going to
start choking the other plants.
He wants us to start with clean ground.
so that's what he's telling us through
the Old Testament is to destroy all the
evil.
Is Is that what you're getting from
that?
I think you're I think that's probably
how I would teach it even if you hadn't
asked that question.
Is that um
Good. Yeah, God wants to He wants us to
do that in our lives where he's got
complete dominion. He doesn't want to
share it with the pagans.
Right.
So, hey, good question, Eva. I
appreciate that.
Thank you for your call tonight.
Our next caller is uh Emma listening
from Toronto, Canada.
Emma, welcome to the program.
Hi, pastors. Good evening.
Evening.
How are you?
We're doing well. How are you?
I'm good. Thank you. Uh I have a
question uh regards to the tithe we pay
in the church. Uh-huh.
Uh I I see some pastors uh preach
against the tithe.
Because they said uh
is the Old Testament.
But now, some some pastors also say,
"Oh, if you don't pay uh tithe, you
don't get blessing from God."
So, I I want to know which is which. Is
it compulsory for us to pay it
because God said it and we have to get
the blessing from God?
That's what I want to know.
Good question. Yeah, there are some
pastors that say, "Well, tithe is an Old
Testament teaching."
Um but there is a New Testament
teaching. The New Testament teaching
would go beyond tithe. It wouldn't be
less than tithe. If you look, for
instance, in um Acts chapter 2, when the
Holy Spirit was poured out, it says that
no man said that anything he had was his
own, but they were selling their houses
and their lands and liquidating their
property and giving it to the church to
spread the gospel.
So, in the Old Testament, it was 10% of
your increase
went towards the proclamation of the
word. Now, Jesus supports that at least
tithe is still in place. Because in
Matthew 23:23,
Christ said to the scribes and the
Pharisees, he said, "You pay tithe of
mint and anise and cumin." Those are the
plants in their herb garden.
And he said, "But you're omitting the
weightier matters of the law, justice,
mercy, and faith. So, these you ought to
do and don't leave the other, the
tithing, undone." Jesus said, "Don't
neglect tithing, but
don't forget about justice, mercy, and
faith. So, the New Testament would
certainly support at least
tithe.
So, if a church is saying, "Oh, the
tithe is the Old Testament." I hope
they're offering the New Testament
teaching, which is a higher percentage
than tithe. Because New Testament
Christians don't have less faith than
Old Testament Christians. See what I'm
saying?
Okay. Does that make sense?
So,
I think it makes sense. So, my question
is
Your phone you know, we can't hear you,
Alma. Your phone is breaking up.
You know, sister, we've got a bad
connection. Uh let Tell you what. We'll
send you a lesson on this that answers
all the questions about tithe in the New
Testament and what the teaching of tithe
is and it's free. The number to call is
800-835-6747.
You can ask for the study guide called
In God We Trust. Again, the number is
800-835-6747. And the study guide is
named is God drew the plans.
Our next caller is uh let's see.
Our next caller is Alexandra listening
from uh let's see. That is North
Carolina.
Alexandra, welcome to the program.
Oh, I think we might have just lost her.
Uh let's go to the
Alexandra, if you call back, we'll put
you on. We don't know what happened
here. We've got Henry listening from the
uh Bronx, New York. Henry, welcome to
the program. Yes. How are you? Doing
well. And a blessed New Year to both of
you.
Well, thank you. Likewise. You can say
that for a few more days and then we'll
be in February. I know. I say that to a
lot of people and they keep on telling
me happy new year. It sounds very
blessed. Uh my question is um
before Jesus Christ comes back,
uh will will all the prophecies be
fulfilled?
All the prophecies up to the second
coming. There are prophecies in the
Bible that talk about the millennium and
there are prophecies in the Bible that
talk about heaven. So, those things
don't happen until, you know, New
Jerusalem comes down, until the
millennium is complete and the judgment.
There's prophecies about the judgment
and the punishment of the wicked. So,
those prophecies still remain, but when
Christ comes back, all of the prophecies
about trouble on Earth will be
fulfilled. Will be fulfilled.
different nations, they'll all be
fulfilled.
So, yeah, do you like studying prophecy?
Uh yes, I do. I do. I do. Yeah. Uh one
more question I want to ask you. Uh
for for people who do believe in God and
what not, and the the ones who were were
not confused,
when judgment day comes,
uh
what will happen to them?
For people who are confused? Well,
of the cuz some people believe in the
that the second of Christ is coming.
Some of them don't believe it. Some of
them believe. Some of them uh some are
confused. If they die being confused,
when judgment day comes, what will
happen? Well, the Lord looks on the
heart, and he knows that if a person is
confused because they're neglecting
knowledge, or if they're confused just
because they are incapable of
understanding, and they just don't have
the evidence.
Uh and, you know, the Lord is going to
if there may be people who will be
redeemed that didn't understand some of
the prophecies and and but they lived up
to the Christian light that they had.
Um
and then there are people the Bible says
some are destroyed for lack of knowledge
because they reject knowledge, and
that's in what Hosea
6:4, I think.
Because you reject knowledge, I'll also
reject you. So, uh it depends on why
they're confused. And um so, the Lord is
merciful though, Henry. I know that.
That is Hosea chapter 4 verse 6 that
you're referring to.
Yeah, I said 6:4. I knew I had that. I
was close.
Hey, thank you very much for your
question, Henry, and appreciate that.
And we're going to take another call. We
got uh Jolie listening from Bronx, New
York. Jolie, welcome to the program.
Hey, how you doing? Good.
How you doing, Pastor Doug?
Doing great.
I'm very glad to hear you cuz I'm
listening to you every Sunday, and I
also watch everything online. And I'm
TV, everything.
Oh, bless your heart.
Very very happy very happy to see you
all the prophecy call and everything
that you have on TV and everything. I'm
very happy. Well, you make sure and tune
in. You know, in about uh 2 weeks Pastor
Ross and I will be in Orlando doing a
new prophecy program that will be live
on the internet.
And it's called Prophecy Encounter.
And, as a matter of fact, all you got to
do is type in prophecyencounter.com,
you'll see the website. You can watch on
Facebook. Everyone out there YouTube.
You can watch it live on YouTube,
Facebook.
And
of things.
Well, my question is
Go ahead.
Yeah, my question is that uh
uh
when I used to go to church, a lot of
churches that I went to, uh you know, I
see it seems to me like they were asking
all the time for money. And I I want I
wonder why a lot of churches
talk too much about money, and I don't
hear that in in your in your ministry. I
don't I never heard anything about
talking about money and stuff like that.
I said, "Why is that? Why is it
different?" Well, we do talk about
money. We we don't make it a priority.
You we um we believe the reason people
give to churches and to ministries like
Amazing Facts is so we can use as much
of the time as possible
talking about the gospel and changing
lives. Then at the end of the program,
you'll notice that we'll say, "Hey, if
you want us to keep this program going."
Cuz this program a lot of churches and
ministries, they they only exist because
people donate.
Uh very few of them get, you know, some
kind of corporate subsidy.
And so, it's important for God's word to
continue that people give. But you and I
know some churches don't manage the
money well, and some churches spend a
lot of time begging for money.
And some pastors
uh you know, they live like kings and
queens and
and um
they're going to give an account for
that someday.
So, um
you know,
Pastor Ross and I, we get a salary. It
doesn't matter whether members in our
church give $10 or a million dollars.
Uh we just get a a fair salary to pay
our expenses and travel and so forth.
And we're in this not for the money.
We're in this to share the gospel and
help people get to heaven.
Very fair. Very fair.
So, yeah, but it's a full-time job.
Yeah, good question. You would also
enjoy that study guide Pastor Ross just
offered called In God We Trust.
The number to call for that is
800-835-6747.
You can ask the study guide called In
God We Trust. Next call is Joe, and he's
listening from New Jersey. Joe, welcome
to the program.
Oh,
Pastor Doug. Yeah.
I've been listening to you for a long
time, and I have a I I just thought of
something that I was
wondering about for a long time.
Uh I've heard
uh a lot of people believe
Peter was the first Pope.
And I've also heard that
he was crucified,
and he requested to be crucified upside
down because he didn't feel he was
worthy to be crucified in the same
manner as Jesus.
Yeah, now that is not in the Bible, but
the reason
I know that. Yeah, that's in the it's
probably true,
but you're not going to find that in the
Bible. I I have read that in Fox's Book
of Martyrs, and some of the early
fathers say that uh Peter, when he was
sentenced by Nero to be crucified, he
told the executioners, "I don't feel
worthy to die like Jesus." And he said,
"Please crucify me with my head down."
And they they accommodated him, and he
probably died even quicker because the
blood rushes to the head, you go
unconscious.
But um on the other question about Jesus
being the first Pope, that that's really
uh kind of a myth that's been often
repeated. Um Jesus is never referred to
as a Pope. As a matter of fact, the
chairman of the uh or rather Peter has
never been referred to as the Pope in
the Bible. The chairman of the first
board meetings there that you have in
Jerusalem was James, the brother of
Jesus.
Um this is some could argue was it
James. People often take that verse that
you find in Matthew 16:18,
where Jesus said, "I say to you, your
name is Peter,
and on this rock I'll build my church,
and the gates of Hades will not prevail
against it." Peter had just said,
"Jesus, you are the Messiah." And Christ
is saying, "You're Peter." And that word
there, Peter, is Petros.
But then he goes on and says, "But on
this rock, this petra." The petra is the
declaration that Peter made, "Jesus, you
are the son of the living God." That's
in verse 16.
Said, "I'm going to build my church."
Jesus did not build his church on Peter.
A few verses later, you find where Jesus
says to Peter, and this is verse 23,
"Get behind me, Satan. You're an offense
to me." So, why would Christ say to
Peter, "You're the foundation on which
the church is going to be built," and a
few verses later he said, "Get behind
me, Satan." That wouldn't make any
sense. Peter was a great apostle, but
the church was not built on him. And by
the way, Peter was married, and none of
the Popes are married. So, there's a
problem there, too.
Hey, listening friends, you can tell
from the music that we're running out of
question time. Do stay tuned a few more
moments. We got some exciting
announcements to share with you. And I
hope you'll go visit the Prophecy
Encounter website. Tune in to this live
series that we're getting ready to do
from Sanford, Florida. That's
prophecyencounter.com.
Also, don't forget we're on this station
because people like you keep us there.
Drop us a note at Amazing Facts and
donate. Thank you very much.
Thank you for listening to today's
broadcast. We hope you understand your
Bible even better than before.
Bible Answers Live is produced by
Amazing Facts, a faith-based ministry
located in Sacramento, California.
Can't get enough Amazing Facts Bible
Study? You don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth-filled
programming. Visit the Amazing Facts
Media Library at aftv.org.
At aftv.org,
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations, as well as printed
material, all free of charge, 24 hours a
day, 7 days a week, right from your
computer or mobile device. Visit
aftv.org.
Are you wondering what lies ahead in
human history, or what recent world
events are harbingers of the end? Are
you ready for the coming crisis?
Landmarks of Prophecy offers clear
answers to your most pressing questions.
Presented by Pastor Doug Batchelor,
Landmarks of Prophecy is a contemporary
video Bible study adventure designed for
today's audiences, presenting the
landmark themes of the Bible in a bright
and compelling way, helping you
understand the Bible better, and giving
you knowledge to face the future with
confidence. Landmarks of Prophecy
contains over 30 hours of exciting video
presentations on six DVDs, plus bonus
question and answer sessions, giving you
keen insight into what lies next in
human history.
If you'd like practical tools to help
you thrive and survive in the here and
now, get Landmarks of Prophecy. Start
your epic Bible study adventure with
Landmarks of Prophecy today by calling
800-538-7275,
or by visiting afbookstore.com.
If you'd like to enhance your study of
God's word, visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org,
and sign up for our free Bible study
course. And make sure to check out our
online bookstore at afbookstore.com,
which offers thousands of inspiring
books, DVDs, and more to help you get
the most out of God's word. To take
advantage of the offers you've heard on
this broadcast, call us at 800-835-6747,
or visit our website at
amazingfacts.org.
Did you enjoy this program? Make sure to
tell your family and friends. Tune in
next time for more Bible Answers Live.
Honest and accurate answers to your
Bible questions.